stranger things is this cool new sort of
mystery sci fi are dramatized heal from
Netflix it said in the 80s and it
borrows a lot from the films of that
time like et and alien the story begins
with the disappearance of a boy called
will from the town of Hawkins Indiana
and the mystery quickly deepens with the
appearance of a girl with psychic powers
a shadowy government agency and a
monster from another dimension by the
end of the season will is found but
there are still heaps of unresolved
questions like what's up with hopper and
the g-man what is the monster and how
does the upside down work what happened
to 11 and why did Nancy hook up with the
douchebag Steve instead of the sensitive
Jonathan was it the hair it was probably
the hair but still let's have a look at
what happened in stranger things season
1 beginning at the very beginning in the
50s and 60s the CIA conducted secret
experiments in a program called MKULTRA
using drugs like LSD to investigate
mind-control brainwashing and
interrogation techniques which is a real
thing that happened by the way but in
stranger things some of these
experiments take place at the Hawkins
National Laboratory led by a certain dr.
Brenner and one of Brenner's subjects
back in the day was a woman called Terry
Ives we learned that Terry was pregnant
while she was being experimented on with
drugs so naturally her child was born
with psychic powers like telekinesis
Terry named the child Jane but Jane was
taken away from her by Brenner who
covered up the kidnapping saying that
Terry actually had a miscarriage
Terry tried to sue Brenna to get her
daughter back but these attempts failed
and Terry seems to have declined into a
drugged out stupor meanwhile Jane grew
up in the Hawkins lab where she was
tattooed with her new name 11:11 calls
dr. Brenner Papa which might mean the
dr. Brenner lied and told Elle that he
was her dad or maybe he really is her
dad maybe he had some relationship with
Terry we don't know but in any case L
was treated cruelly at the lab Brenner
subjects there are lots of experiments
making her break things with her mind
and perceive things from a distance
sometimes he put eleven in a sensory
deprivation tank where Elevens able to
psychically project herself into a weird
dark void where she can interact with
people who are far away this is during
the Cold War so Brenner any CIA buddies
user to spy on Russians but also in this
- 11 encounters a monster the monster
presumably isn't physically in this dark
space but is in its own dimension the
upside down just as the Russian is in
Russia and Elevens in the tank but by
projecting herself through this dark
space xi is able to reach across the
dimensions land under the orders of
Brenner she makes contact with the
monster somehow causing a tear in time
and space making a gate a portal into
the monsters dimension allowing it to
emerge into Hawkins in the commotion xi
escapes the lab by crawling through a
drainpipe meanwhile the monster starts
to hunt animals and people in Hawkins at
the start of episode one it takes will
so this kicks off the human drama of the
story we see Will's mother Joyce
frantically trying to connect with her
son and Will's older brother Jonathan
searching in his angst and alienation we
see the cop Jim hopper still haunted by
his daughter's death and when eleven
escapes from the lab she groups up with
Will's friends Mike and Lucas and Dustin
who teach her loyalty and normalcy and
love there's also a Mike sister Nancy
who's growing up trying to work out who
she is discovering sex like when we
first see Nancy Dustin offers her some
sausage and pepperoni pizza which Nancy
declines this refusal to take the
sausage kind of her shadows her conflict
over whether to sleep with a boyfriend
Steve or to listen to a friend Bob and
stay a virgin Bob for her part dies and
no one seems to care but Steve gets a
redemption of sorts after being an
[ __ ]
early on in the end Nancy and Steve are
together but there's still a bit of a
love triangle with Jonathan so yeah
there's some interesting drama happening
but the really juicy mysteries surround
the upside down the upside-down seems to
be a sort of an alternate dimension it
has the same stuff in it as the real
world all the buildings and trees and
cars of Hawkins are there but
everything's dark and dead and decayed
cold and empty when stuff moves or
changes in the real Hawkins nothing
seems to change or move in the upside
down so it's almost like this is a
snapshot a frozen moment in time perhaps
of what Hawkins was like at the moment
of contact when eleven touched the
monster maybe it was at that moment that
this whole dimension was created or
maybe the upside-down used to be alive
and normal like Hawkins but it was
infected by this weird toxic growth we
see
in the upside down there are vines or
tentacles on the ground slime on the
walls particles in the air the gate
seems to grow and wherever the monster
goes slimed spreads maybe this is like
an interdimensional disease spreading
from parallel world to parallel world
infecting the multiverse or maybe this
is a time-travel thing maybe the upside
down is the future of Hawkins it's what
it'll become after being infected by its
own future this is all wild speculation
but whatever the upside down is it's
clearly closely connected to Hawkins the
dimensions affect each other in lots of
different ways activity in the upside
down can cause electrical disturbance in
Hawkins will and joists can even use
lights to communicate though we don't
know how this works on wills end how can
he even see the lights and letters from
the upside down some people think this
means Will has psychic powers like 11
which could maybe also explain this
weird gate like thing that will seems to
open but the evidence is unclear
anyway the upside-down can also affect
Hawkins through magnetism
apparently the gate has a strong
electromagnetic field and sound can
cross the dimensions John oh here's
Nancy when she's in the upside-down the
very walls in Hawkins can give way to
the upside down which allows the monster
to enter the monster also called the
demagogue on is the creature that kind
of looks like a human but with long arms
and five unfolding petals of teeth
instead of a face after 11 makes the
gate
the monster is able to make small
portals of its own crossing into Hawkins
to drag prey into the upside down like a
shark it's apparently drawn by blood
the monster hunts for food but it also
uses prey for other purposes in Episode
eight we see that Will has been stuck in
some gross organic fleshy web like an
alien with a slimy tentacles on his
throat like a face hugger maybe like an
alien the creature uses human hosts to
reproduce maybe the little slugs that
emerge from the bodies of Bob and will a
little baby demagogue uns though that
doesn't explain the hatched egg we see
earlier on in the upside down maybe
that's the egg that monster hatched from
but if so what laid the egg it looks too
big to come out of a demagogue also the
first time we see them
so it looks like it's eating that same
egg so between the monster the eggs that
facehugger tentacles and the cough up
slugs there must be some complex
symbiotic lifecycle happening here there
must be other creatures involved maybe
there are big egg-laying slug Queens or
juvenile demagogue uns out there maybe
this creature is an alien
well maybe the monster is something more
human one popular theory is that the
monster somehow represents Elevens
darker half like maybe the monster is a
psychic manifestation of her anger and
fear and her suffering at the Hawkins
lab and that in that moment of contact
when the gate was made she brought the
monster out of her sub consciousness and
into the real world
maybe that's what el means when she says
monster this idea could help explain
some similarities between El on the
monster like in Episode one we see the
monster open a lock without touching it
just as 11 locks a lock the monster
appears to have telekinetic abilities
just like LLL also 11 seems to recognize
a photo of will without having met him
before
maybe she recognizes him because her
other half the monster has abducted will
when el defeats the monster both she and
the monster disappear as though they
kind of cancelled each other out maybe
el and the monster merged back into one
the monster returning to its place in
Elle's consciousness maybe changing her
for the worse
all that said if L is the monster how do
we explain the complex biology of the
upside down could that have possibly
come from Elle's mind finally it's very
interesting that when L uses her powers
we see the same weird electrical effects
that are associated with the upside down
so there's got to be some link here it's
all very uncertain but there are clearly
strong connections between eleven and
the monster and the upside down at the
end of season one L and the monster
disappear will comes home and we get a
1-month leader where everything seems
calm and normal the buyers have
Christmas dinner the boys play D&D Steve
and Nancy get John a camera to replace
the one that Steve broke all seems well
but we see some newspaper clippings that
show that there's still a lot going on
Joyce has told the media about Brenner's
experiments of the lab leading to a
massive investigation the car
who is involved in wills fake body has
been caught and there's a shake-up among
the state troopers who worked with
Brenna's people to cover stuff up it
seems to the secrets of the Hawkins lab
are being revealed to the world but it
may be that nothing comes of this
because MKULTRA was supposedly exposed
before but there are more cool details
the article quotes someone named Ives
expressing disgust about the lab which
is weird because Becky Ives doesn't seem
to believe any of this conspiracy stuff
and Terry Ives doesn't seem to speak so
what's going on is Terry talking again
could she maybe have a reunion with her
daughter 11 finally the article mentions
Brenner last we saw him he was attacked
by the monster but this suggests that he
survives and comments from Brenna's
actor and the Dhafir brothers have all
been confirmed that we will be seeing
printer again which brings us to season
2 season 2 of stranger things is set for
release in 2017 and there's already a
lot of info out about it the show's
creators have said that the season will
be like a sequel to the first apparently
it will explore the repercussions of
everything that happened last season
while also introducing new problems and
questions there are new characters
including max and Billy and Roman max is
a sort of a tomboy with a complicated
history
Billy is her stepbrother hyper confident
and violent and Roman is an outsider
with a rough past who seeks revenge for
a great loss suffered at an early age
all these characters sound potentially
interesting it'll be cool to see how
they fit in with the existing cast also
a teaser trailer for season 2 has
revealed 9 episode titles which give
tantalizing hints of what's to come
the first title Mad Max is evocative of
the Mad Max movies but probably refers
to the character max the boy who came
back to life has a Harry Potter vibe but
we know this refers to will just like on
the newspaper a lot of the other stuff
could kind of mean anything but the
pumpkin patch could maybe be like a
field of eggs like an alien the palace
could be some kind of important base the
storm could be either a general
metaphorical conflict or maybe more
literally some kind of interdimensional
upside down II kind of storm a Polliwog
is a tadpole like the pokeyman which
could perhaps refer to these slugs if
they're like baby demagogues or
something The Secret cabin sounds like a
good place for 11 or someone to hide and
the brain could maybe refer
some kind of intelligence behind the
creatures of the upside down maybe some
kind of hive mind [ __ ]
finally the lost brother might refer to
a test subject like 11 who was taken
away from their sibling maybe this is
the great loss suffered by Roman so
there are million cool new possibilities
for season 2 here but let's also have a
look at what might happen to the
characters we already know and love
season 1 ends with this creepy scene
where will coughs up a slug just like
the one that came out of Bob and then
will seems to flicker for a moment into
the upside-down
apparently the upside down has done
something bad to will and there are lots
of different theories about what this
may be
since he got facehugger tentacled some
people think he's got monster eggs or
monster slugs growing inside him or even
that he's turning into a monster another
possibility is that his time in the
upside down has given him some kind of
power to see into that dimension that
he's connected somehow but there are
also questions about how this is
affected will as a person like he's seen
some [ __ ] right he struggled to survive
in a nightmare bizarro world hunted by a
horrific monster isolated from all he
knows for a week at the age of like 12
that must have had an impact on him
surely so season 2 might explore this
but the character we really care about
here is 11 right when and how will she
come back we do know that she'll come
back if only because of those waffles
hopper leaves out for her but what will
happen with her as a character she's got
this great identity conflict where on
one hand she wants to be pretty and she
wants to be normal
well on the other hand she grew up as a
government weapon and sees herself as a
monster this is why her relationship
with Mike is so beautiful he doesn't
want her to wear a wig or be a weapon he
accepts her for who she is
but else still has a long way to go in
working out her identity and hopefully
season two we'll continue to explore
this there are also questions about her
powers we've seen L throw a van into an
air levitate people smush people's
brains make a kid pee projector self
across space and dimensions rip holes in
space-time itself what else might she be
capable of we got a taste of a greater
power in her confrontation with the
monster her eyes go kind of red and she
goes all super saiyan on the monsters
ass there are lots of parallels here
with a Marvel Comics character Jean Grey
forms into a massively powerful psychic
being called Dark Phoenix the comic in
which this happens x-men number 134 is
specifically referenced in stranger
things by Dustin and will so maybe as
with Jane Grey will see a Wilder much
more destructive side 211 in season 2
another great character is hopper season
1 explored his grief over the death of
his daughter Sara and we see his
memories of her driving him in the
search for will it seems like he still
needs some closure here and there are
hints that there might be more to reveal
about Sara's death Hopper's actor
described it as a secret in a recent AMA
some fans speculate that Sara might have
had powers like ill there are also
questions about hoppers connections to
Brenna and the government men in episode
8 we see hopper get in a black
government car what's he up to
we know that earlier in the episode
hopper made a deal with dr. brenner
Brenna let hope and Joy's through the
gate and in return Hope gave Brenna what
the likely answer is that hopper told
Brenna where to find my canal
that's how Brenna knew to come to the
high-school gym you can argue that that
was the right strategic move wills life
was at stake and xi can protect herself
but still hop totally betrayed them if
Joyce and the boys find out we could
have problems
finally it'll be great to find out more
about Brenna and the lab and the
government men the bad men we don't even
know what to call these guys because
they really don't know who they are Hopf
suggests the CIA the NSA Department of
Energy others say the military we know
they're working with the state troopers
but yeah it's really unclear who these
guys are
we've seen them do some really extreme
[ __ ] they murdered Benny and made it
look like a suicide they drugged and
bugged hop they moved Barb's car to make
it law actually ran away and they made a
lifelike fake corpse of a dead child
they listen in on everyone's phone calls
and they use these hawkins power and
light guys to spy whoever they are these
guys have heaps of resources and are
ruthless in pursuing their goals but
what are their goals clearly they're
interested in eleven psychic powers but
there must be more to it why was Brenna
so keen to get ultimate contact with the
monster what do they know about the
upside down who else might they have
experimented on
if eleven is the eleventh subject of
their ten or more
other subjects out there the duffer's
have promised a lot more back story
about branner and 11 and all that so
it'll be awesome to dig deeper into that
history
so basically season 1 of stranger things
was pretty bloody great and the sequel
season 2 is looking pretty good too what
questions would you like to see answered
next season and what do you want to see
next row mulch if Dex remember to Like
and subscribe and check out our Game of
Thrones videos if you keen thanks to the
patrons who support this channel on
patreon including the Steve franchise
Stephanie nasty Philip bone of jacob sax
rock McClaren Jennifer Himalaya Vijay
Singh Benjamin nogal algea skl Ian bill
Quinn and r.i.p Bosman bonus bits she is
you